Trascrizione: Marco Caresia
Revisore: Federico Sangati
Buongiorno!
Io di cosa vi parlerò, vi parlerò della
più brutta malattia che c'è in Italia
che è il fatalismo protestatario.
Sapete che cos'è
il fatalismo protestario?
E' quella malattia, quel virus che
la nostra popolazione alberga
si tiene dentro
e che praticamente ci fa dire
vabbè ma...
vabbè...
non si può fare niente
non si può cambiare
in questo paese non c'è niente da fare
vabbè...
potrei inventarmi un nuovo virus
il virus vabbè...
e vi parlerò d come se vogliamo
sconfiggere questo virus dobbiamo
credere nel cambiamento e soprattutto
dobbiamo avere coraggio
di investire nel cambiamento
e dobbiamo avere la voglia
di metterci in gioco noi stessi.
Io vi parlerò della mia esperienza
vi racconterò una storia vera
una testimonianza
che però vuole essere una speranza
per tutti i ragazzi e ragazze soprattutto
che si occupano di ricerca
che vogliono diciamo
cambiare questo paese e che
vogliono mettersi in gioco
per un'Italia migliore
soprattutto se lo fanno
da un ente pubblico
perché io sono 25 anni che lavoro
in un ente pubblico
del servizio sanitario nazionale
e sono orgogliosa di farlo
e voglio dimostrarvi che anche nel
servizio pubblico
si possono fare delle cose straordinarie.
Allora il primo dogma di cui vi parlerò
perché voglio infrangere dei dogma
voglio mostrarvi
che che è possibile infrangerli
è che in Italia
non si può fare ricerca di eccellenza
allora questo non è vero, ve lo dico io
ma lo sapete, avete anche qui in trentino
tanti centri di eccellenza
quello però che è vero è che ci
vogliono mille braccia
cioè non è che qua
è tanto facile fare ricerca
ci vogliono mille braccia
bisogna combattere la burocrazia
bisogna combattere l'ingessatura
della rigidità mentale
dei nostri amministratori
e bisogna lavorare sodo
lavorare tantissimo
ma soprattutto
bisogna saper cavalcare le tigri
perché le tigri passano
e se avete la conoscenza, l'impegno,
la consapevolezza
che quella è una tigre che va cavalcata
voi non dovete spaventarvi
e dovete cavalcare la tigre
perché le tigri rappresentano
delle grandissimi opportunità
per far emergere il nostro talento
e le nostre capacità.
Allora io sono un veterinario
ho studiato veterinaria sapete perché?
Perché volevo andare via di casa.
Io sono di Roma
e l'unica facoltà scientifica
che non c'era a Roma era veterinaria
e quindi io ho preso
ho convinto i miei genitori
che mi piacevano tantissimo gli animali
che peraltro è anche vero
insomma a me piacciono gli animali
però come a tutti
cioè vogliamo bene agli animali
abbiamo sentito prima
però sapevo che non avrei mai esercitato
anche perché se uno non è portato
meglio che non esercita
e quindi sono andata a studiare
veterinaria, contro la famiglia e tutti
e poi non sono più tornata a casa.
Poi la vita ti porta dove ti porta
a me ha portato
a studiare i virus emergenti
sono quei virus che dal serbatoi animale
si spostano all'essere umano
e possono provocare diciamo
delle catastrofi
come per esempio il virus dell'HIV
perché anche se noi pensiamo
di essere diversi dagli animali
un po' lo siamo
però dal punto di vista del virus
noi non è che siamo tanto diversi
perché il virus cerca i recettori
e i recettori nostri
sull'apparato respiratorio
sono uguali ai recettori di un maiale
un animale a caso
e quindi questi virus abbastanza
agevolmente fanno il salto di specie
e quando entrano in una popolazione nuova
possono veramente creare dei disastri
allora io sono
si sente che non sono veneta?
Sono romana e però sono quasi
16 anni che vivo in Veneto
mia figlia, che è qui, parla veneto
perché è nata in Veneto
e sono arrivata
all'istituto zooprofilattico
di cui c'è una sezione anche a Trento
che lavora molto bene
nel 1998 era un laboratorio piccolo
eravamo 6, 7 persone
facevamo diagnostica a livello locale
sulle malattie degli animali del Veneto
e non incidevamo per niente
a livello internazionale
anche perché
scusate io lo dico sempre
nella speranza che qualcosa accada
un ente che si chiama
istituto zooprofilattico...
cambiamo nome!
Quando dico dove lavoro
nell'istituto zooprofilattico
e che fate dei preservativi
per gli elefanti?
Ecco non proprio però...
Al di là di questo io farò una
battaglia per cambiare nome
eravamo un gruppetto
di ragazzi volenterosi
però nel 1999 in Veneto e in Lombardia
si è verificata la più grande
e devastante epidemia
di influenza aviaria
che si fosse mai verificata al mondo
io mi sono trovata a dover gestire
questa epidemia con grandissima fatica
con impegno mio e dei miei collaboratori
ma era una malattia
sulla quale bisognava investire
abbiamo capito chie era essenziale
sviluppare nuove tecnologie
e abbiamo sviluppato il primo sistema
di vaccinazione al mondo
per questa malattia
e questo sistema è oggi incluso
nella legislazione europea.
Questa è stata la prima tigre.
Da questo il gruppo di 6, 7 persone è
diventato un gruppo di 70 persone
leader a livello internazionale
riconosciuto da organismi come la FAO
come l'Organizzazione Mondiale
della Sanità Animale,
la Commissione Europea
e siamo riusciti a tirare
tantissimi finanziamenti
in 5 anni abbiamo attirato
12 milioni di euro per fare ricerca
sapere quanti ragazzi si pagano
con 12 milioni di euro?
Il mio gruppo ha una quarantina
di ragazzi che lavorano
precari, ma sono precari
che si fanno un curriculum
che imparano a lavorare
nell'ambito di un progetto europeo
e sono diventati loro stessi
leader nel loro ambito
tant'è che vanno a parlare in America
i miei ragazzi vanno e vengono
invitati a parlare in America.
Il secondo dogma di cui vi voglio parlare
è che noi siamo in Italia
ai confini dell'impero
cioè l'Italia non conta niente o poco
e quindi... cambiare!
Io ci credo nella sanità pubblica
e ci credo veramente in quello che faccio
e quando ci credi così, devi avere
una missione e devi riuscire anche
a cambiare le cose
che magari non sono giuste.
Ci sono un sacco di cose che
non sono giuste che succedono
e allora ti viene detto
che non è possibile cambiare i meccanismi
di politica sanitaria internazionale
da Legnaro, Padova, Italy
Certo difficile perché un conto è
se sei al CDC di Atlanta
o se sei al Pasteur di Parigi
un conto se lavori
all'istituto zooprofilattico
a Legnaro, Padova, Italy
però anche qui non è vero
e la storia del mio gruppo lo testimonia
vi ricorderete l'influenza aviaria
del 2003-2004
questo virus H5N1 era un virus
che preocupava moltissimo
la comunità scientifica
perché il virus dell'influenza aviaria
è il virus più aggressivo
che vi è nel regno animale.
Se voi foste tutti pennuti
tutti pennuti
se il virus entrasse qua dentro
vi ucciderebbe tutti!
I virus di solito non fanno così
perché un virus che uccide tutti
non è tanto intelligente
perché poi che fa?
E' disoccupato!
Quindi è un virus con una virulenza
e una cattiveria estrema.
Beh, questo virus
dell'influenza aviaria H5N1
ad un certo punto ha fatto
la bella pensata di cominciare
ad infettare le persone e di uccidere
il 50% delle persone che infettava
e quindi,
scusate ma se voi foste un virologo
vi preoccupereste con una diffusione
di questa epidemia a livello planetario?
Fidatevi c'era da preoccuparsi
e quindi insomma
c'era tutto il sistema sanitario
che si occupa a livello internazionale
di questo patologia in allerta.
Bene, questo virus
a un certo punto dall'Asia
dal Vietnam, dalla Thailandia
e dalla Cina, attraversa l'asia centrale
e arriva in Europa
è arrivato anche qua da noi
arriva in Europa,
però qua siamo organizzati
abbiamo i servizi veterinari ,
abbiamo gli istituti zooprofilattici
abbiamo la polizia, l'esercito,
abbiamo i soldi
per risolvere i problemi.
Arriva in Africa
e là è un po' diversa la situazione
perché non hanno neanche
gli occhi per piangere
quindi questo virus che uccide
il 100% dei pennuti
ha steso tantissimi pennuti
e le popolazioni più povere
non avevano più pennuti da mangiare
Punto numero uno.
Secondo, c'era il rischio che
un virus del genere
infettando delle persone
nelle quali vi è una estesa positività
per il virus HIV
che è un virus immuno repressivo
voi capite che
si profilava veramente una catastrofe!
Insomma mi chiamarono
perché nel frattempo
eravamo dentro questi progetti europei.
Mi chiamarono da uno di questi laboratori
da un laboratorio nigeriano
e mi dissero
possiamo mandarti il virus?
Abbiamo il primo virus africano
vorremmo che voi lo caratterizzaste.
E quindi il nostro laboratorio
è stato il primo
a caratterizzare, a srotolare,
a guardare il genoma
di questo virus H5N1 nigeriano
che tutto il mondo voleva conoscere
perché non si sapeva come fosse arrivato
come si spostava, quanto fosse virulento
Beh, una volta visto il virus
mi chiamò uno dell'OMS e mi disse
senti Ilaria, se tu ci dai
l'impronta digitale del virus
la sequenza, noi lo mettiamo
in un database ad accesso limitato
e poi diamo la password.
A questo datobase ci hanno accesso
una quindicina di laboratori
quelli più importanti
così anche tu magari
diventi più importante.
E io secondo voi cosa gli ho detto?
Gli ho detto di no!
Ma scusate, ma a voi
vi pare una cosa logica?
Siamo di fronte a una potenziale pandemia
che potrebbe stendere il 50% dell'umanità
allora io lavoro con i soldi vostri
con i soldi del contribuente europeo
l'istituto zooprofilattico
è un ente pubblico
allora secondo voi, io la mia sequenza,
la mia ricetta, il mio tesoretto
lo metto in un database ad accesso
limitato al quale possono avere accesso
solo 15 laboratori, di fatto
escludendo a migliaia e migliaia
di ricercatori di poterci lavorare
ma al di là di questo, di fatto
andando contro quelli che sono
gli interessi della sanità pubblica
io gli ho detto no
gli ho detto di no
e mi sono messa però
in un pasticcio gigantesco ovviamente
perché quei 15
si sono arrabbiati ovviamente
è venuto Science da noi
che non è che viene tanto spesso
sono andata a finire
sul Wall Street Journal
ho avuto 2 pagine
e poi vorrei che notaste
guarda qua, sembro Buddha!
Ma vi pare a voi?
Uno fa tanto l'Italiano un po' trendy
carina lei, è guarda che ti tocca
va in giro per tutto il mondo
hanno detto, "questa ha le orecchie così"
Vabbè...
Il New York Times e Nature hanno preso
e sostenuto questa campagna e
per chi è un scientist qua dentro
io ho avuto hip hip urrà da Nature
"3 cheers" per Ilaria Capua
che andrà sul mio epitaffio.
Però al di là di questo
è partito un dibattito internazionale
su questa faccenda
e oggi le cose sono cambiate
sono cambiate
perché varie organizzazioni
non la faccio tanto lunga
ma in particolare l'OMS
che era quella che mi aveva detto
mettilo nel nostro database
ad accesso limitato
ci ha messo 5 anni
perché sono un po' lenti all'OMS
ma alla fine l'hanno fatto
hanno fatto questo comunicato stampa
e hanno passato questa risoluzione
che dice
°una svolta epocale, noi promuoviamo la
trasparenza dei dati
e promuoviamo il libero accesso
alle informazioni
quando siamo a rischio di una pandemia"
e tutto questo è venuto dai confini
dell'impero, a Legnaro, Padova, Italy
Io penso di non essere un genio
sono una normale
ho fatto una cosa di buon senso l'ho
fatta col cuore, l'ho fatta perché
io ci credo in quello che faccio
Mi hanno messo nei 50 scienziati
migliori del mondo ma vi pare a voi!
Ma vi pare!
Sono stata bollata del nome
"revolutionary mind"
che veramente non mi merito
però ragazzi, voi che lavorate
in biomedicina
voi che vi dedicate alla scienza
guardate che le cose si possono fare
e il mondo se ne accorge!
Adesso molto rapidamente
perché ho 2 minuti e 33
Vi parlerò del terzo dogma
che proprio mi sta qua
e che è questo: il soffitto di cristallo.
Le donne non riescono mai a
raggiungere le posizioni apicali.
Signore, sapete quando vi regalano quei
mazzi di fiori che dentro ci sono
tipo 5 o 6 rose
e lo portate a casa, le mettete nel vaso
e la mattina dopo la rosa come è?
Ecco, il talento femminile
in Italia è così.
Noi facciamo studiare le nostre ragazze
le nostre figle vanno all'università
fanno il dottorato, sono bravissime
e poi dopo non riescono a sbocciare
non riescono a mostrare a tutto il mondo
il loro talento, e non riescono
a restituire all'Italia
quello che l'Italia ha dato loro.
Quindi le ragazze sono più brave
è vero o no?
Mamme e papà, è vero!
Studiano di più che vogliamo fare?
E' così.
E può essere
che ottengano titoli migliori
studio meglio, sono più efficaci
e poi... si perdono, si perdono.
Cosa fa? La segretaria.
Cosa fa? Lavoro su internet.
Lasciamo perdere...
Cosa fa?
Non è possibile!
E quello che però voglio dire
che noi siamo in italia
il sistema non aiuta, però ragazze
aprite bene le orecchie
qua nessuno regala niente
a nessuno, manco ai maschi
allora però, sappiate che l'unico,
l'unico elemento essenziale
e insostituibile per diventare
donne di successo
è la voglia
la voglia matta, la voglia di emergere,
la voglia di fare delle salite durissime
la voglia di prendere delle sberle
che ti rompono l'osso del collo
che le devi prendere, perché scusate
qualcuno qua dentro non ha mai preso
delle sberle nella vita?
Le sberle si prendono, si prendono
e ti metti in piedi e ricominci
e quindi arriveranno le ingiustizie
arriveranno le difficoltà
però dovete essere orgogliose di essere
motori del cambiamento
e dovete essere orgogliose
del vostro lavoro
perché solo così noi potremmo sperare
in un'Italia migliore
perché l'Italia non può fare a meno
del talento femminile
perché se sono più brave
noi che facciamo, le lasciamo a casa?
Ma vi pare una cosa intelligente?
Bisogna che da un lato
il sistema le aiuti
ma dall'altro anche le ragazze
si aiutino da sole
ed è difficile
lo sappiamo che è difficile
perché abbiamo un mondo interiore
che è fatto di essere mamma
di essere sorella di essere figlia
però ragazze
tirate fuori le unghie e i denti
e fate vedere quello che sapete fare!
Questa è la mia penultima diapositiva
e ve la faccio vedere
perché l'Economist
ha fatto una graduatoria
delle persone influenti nel 2013.
Io sono questa,
si sono sbagliati secondo me.
Sono questa e non questa.
Lavoro in un ente pubblico
sono un veterinario
che si occupa di ricerca
e voglio essere una testimonianza
per tutte voi
perché il limite
deve essere il cielo.
Grazie!